12 minutes 12 minutes aidez-moi
aidez-moi bloquer la voiture
aidez moi aidez moi le mec est en sang
et la personne d'à côté continue met le
plein quoi mais c 'est c'est une scène
surréaliste
il est 9h30 du matin lundi 10 septembre
nous sommes dans une station-service à
dijon le conducteur de la mercedes grise
est venu faire le plein pour son patron
jérôme et il va se faire agresser aux
yeux de tous une personne qui se défait
un petit peu pendant pendant que le
malheureux se faire complètement quart
des français pendant de longues minutes
la scène se poursuit mais personne n'ose
intervenir il ya au total six ou sept
personnes pendant douze minutes je sais
pas on se regarde on se dit tiens on va
aider le mec mais là c'est sais je mets
mon essence je n'ai rien vu j'ai rien
entendu
il se fait écraser par la voiture
[Musique]
laquelle de l'artisan il recule comme
ils l'entendent cash il regarde il remet
la première île par la cie mais on n'est
plus dans le civisme détendre on est
dans l'abject alors si la personnel un
couteau il n'y a pas de sujet là
pistolet il n'y a pas de sujet personnel
à rien quand je vois certains
commentaires qui sont mis sur des
réseaux sociaux
à n'en faut surtout pas bouger il
pourrait nous arriver quelque chose mais
met une voiture en face à pelé des
passants voilà se mettent à 3 pour
ceinturer quelqu'un c'est toujours mieux
qu'une catastrophe qui va arriver
deux heures après ce car jacking
l'agresseur est arrêté à lyon il a foncé
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport sans faire
de blessé las il a décidé de prendre
l'avion ou de rentrer dans un avion je
ne serai pas l'anc est le livre mais
s'il avait décidé d'aller au
centre-ville d'écraser les gens comme ça
s'est passé à nice est-ce qu'on peut pas
s'unir pour essayer de régler le
problème comme ça c'est passé plusieurs
fois dans l'actualité
plutôt que de se dire oh la la si par
malheur je lui fais quelque chose ça va
se retourner contre moi ça c'est trop
facile et c'est trop individualiste
ce manque de réaction des témoins lors
d'une agression est appelée dans les
experts
l'effet spectateurs
[Musique]